[Music]
if I die
now
Thank You Shan
I
why
name
[Applause]
[Music]
Norman
my my my
[Music]
Oh
right
[Music]
hey guys it's been at the Dilla g4g
checker here and in this video I'm going
to see how much I can make back from the
magpie and blings that I had purchased
by the hard clue Scrolls initially I
tried buying ninja and blings but it
turned out to be very expensive and I
was losing money very quick as much as I
wanted to get the urea moat the 300
heart cruise growth milestone I was
losing money as if it was falling on my
hands I'm gonna throw a picture up on
the screen for you guys so I can show
you how much I bought in terms of the
magpie dimpling stain the total loop it
was the number that's showing at the
bottom for the total value of the
Magpies that I purchased was the actual
price added up between all the
transactions that I made to buy all of
those implants I didn't buy them all at
once I did earn the 97 mil to buy the
magpie handlings so I didn't take any
money away from my bank I didn't take
any money away from my other accounts
everything was earned over time all the
money that I was earning during that
period when I started doing the hard
cuzco streamed i was dedicating a
hundred percent of the money earned
towards the magpie a blank so that goes
that goes in line with what i was
teaching you guys in the managing risk
video so now regardless of whether or
not i lost any money at all with a
magpie in playings i already probably
profited well I guess I guess that's a
way to look at it but my bank isn't
going to be hurt because I had hurry
I had already segmented off money
specifically for the magpie in planes
and the thighs lost 97
million then I had lost 797 million but
I knew that's kind of like impossible
unless like I just drop everything on
the floor but why don't we go ahead and
look at the loot from all the infant
jars so we have our 9 clamp Ling's
and if you didn't know when you open a
jar
sometimes the jar will break so that's
why there's not you know 6090 of beans
[Music]
okay so we're going to price check this
guys and we're going to see how much
this is again right now might be a
little bit different from earlier okay
so it's showing me the first price that
is showing total guide price that's the
native runescape client price which is
showing about ninety point seven mil
whereas the OS lady client is showing me
ninety one point two mil you don't know
always buddy is a little bit more
accurate so we're going to go ahead and
tally this off as ninety one point two
mil which gives us a loss of about six
mil let's say that's how much I lost
that's a huge difference between the
Ninja and blings I invested in and the
magpie implica invested in if I had
purchased 100 mil worth of ninja and
blings
I just don't even want to know what the
end loot was going to be since we have
the loot now we want to figure out how
we can try and squeeze as much money out
of this as we possibly can
[Music]
so something very strange happened while
I was editing in this video I don't know
how this happened
thought I have to show you guys kind of
my setup here so I can show you
well how much we ended up in the end
after kind of sold everything off I kind
of recorded it over the software that I
use and if you can see here I'm kind of
using the scroll on the player you can
see that I'm kind of scrolling back and
forth should we move this up a little
bit you can see that I'm kind of going
back and forth to kind of go down that
timeline of that clip it ends there so
it never really shows the loot and this
is the tile that save that might appear
then I go the opposite way to see we
like those and I tried uploading this
video and I've tried watching it I've
tried watching it without the software
and it acts similar to what it's showing
right now it's not showing the loot
so by mistake I found out a way to find
the missing file somehow it's weird but
here's the total loot from everything
that was sold - the snapdragon seeds
okay so in total OS buddy was estimating
a total value of around ninety 1.2 mil
but in the end we were able to obtain
ninety two point three four mil but I
had to say that I kind of screwed up
somewhere along the lines I don't
believe I recorded those some some bit
of this because I remember at the very
end of this actually ended up with
around 97 98 mil so I made a couple mil
off of kind of doing the stuff that I
did
maybe it wasn't 97 98 mail maybe was
like 96 mil but it was definitely more
than one milk
so I do apologize for that you can
either take you can either take my word
on how much I that I made or you can
just take out my word for what I can
show and prove to you what videos and
pictures alright and now we have the
actual loop really hard clues now the
little disclaimer before we get into
that real quick though the teleports
that you guys see in this tab to spank
tempura here are teleports that I
actually used while doing these clue
Scrolls so it's not 100% loot on these
specific teleport at but if to click on
the actual clue tab itself I kind of
took everything out of here so
everything kind of just jumbled up and
so mess again
but OS buddies showing a loot of around
twenty four point six mil and this
doesn't look so organized so what I have
right now is I have my year account
right here
as if you guys remember we had the drop
party not too long ago
so is this quickly to do this place all
placeholders yes there we go okay now I
have a clean slate I'm going to go ahead
and transfer all of these items over to
the URI account and then I'm going to
organize it to look a little bit nicer
[Music]
all right here we are so first off I
think this is the best that I could
organize it we don't have all the items
so it's a little difficult trying to
kind of make all the sets here and there
if you guys are curious in terms of
what's in the first tab nothing it's
just the briefcase so that it kind of
helps out with the scrolling here
because initially when I have the first
tab just open and no other tabs it was
like an infinite scroll bar
it was super small I decided to create a
second tab specifically for hard
crucibles and in the future my goal is
to unlock all the end goal rewards
they're all tier two Scrolls
so that means easy clue medium and then
the elite as well as master but in terms
of the master I'm not going to be
camping that one because it's going to
be I mean I could spend like two years
trying to camp the bloodhound pad you'll
never get it
so if so the other the other tiers I do
still plan on doing those for live
streams and I'm actually going to
include them into this account as well
the URI account is going to now be like
the official clue school library for all
the clues that I got on my account and
then I've screen for you guys as of
right now everything is on this one tab
from all the our clues goals but what
I'm going to do in the future is I'm
going to separate the common drops that
you get from all tiers into one tab and
then separate the easy medium and hard
and elite tabs into their own categories
and then if we ever get into mastery or
clues
then we'll obviously make a tab for that
but I'll go ahead and just do a little
scroll here for you guys so you guys can
see what it might look like have your
teleport Scrolls have your god Wars book
so we completed the full set of Saruman
a full set of Zam rock only one of each
a full set of armadillo
only one of each didn't get to fulfill
the context didn't get to fill the
ancient or the Bandos and that ancient
would have been nice to have filled
because we would have at least had like
two of those kind of recovery kind of
lucky on getting one of those because
these are these are quite expensive 630
K 488 ek Junoon forties UK it adds up so
let's go down a little more we have our
prized possessions of these streams are
almost 1 mil or around 1 mil D hide but
let's see what else some of these were
are a little bit pricey 100 DK 250 K we
have quite a lot of alcohols here 1 mil
1.7 million item was the gilded square
shield so nothing too exciting there but
see how that looks like it guys don't
criticize me too much on my
organizational skills I try to do the
best that I possibly can
I initially wanted to kind of include
all the god sets together but seeing as
how there's so many items missing from
the hard clue set this was the best I
could do but other than that guys please
chair to subscribe for future content we
should leave a like to show your support
are you sure to leave a comment down
below to give your opinion on this video
and any kind of videos you guys wanna
see in the future but other than that
good luck merchandize and enjoyment
Oh
you